Merida is so nice seeing you listen I
thought last season was one of the most
intense seasons in Housewives history
and then I saw the trailer for this
season are we ready for this
I hope so because it's coming on
September 28th like it or not
I love this what are you excited for the
fans to see
um you know I'm excited for
people to have some level of
understanding of the place I was in last
year
um it had been a really difficult winter
you know and
um
I had a lot of things I really couldn't
talk about they weren't my story to tell
um and things I was very sensitive to
you know like
I didn't want to delve crazy into stuff
with my father because my sister you
know or whatever and
um
there were a lot of things and so I I
hope a lot of that gets flushed out this
season I guess we'll see
well I know that you spent a lot of time
in France you left Salt Lake City what
was that experience like for you
yeah I spent most of um July and August
in France Italy and London and I last
summer I was in France for about a month
I've been going to Europe during the
Summers for quite a while it just keeps
getting longer and longer and longer
that I'm spending there especially now
that I'm an empty nester
um you know what it was wonderful it's
like I love to go to all the like us you
know hot spots there where it's crazy
parties and I also like to go to the
quieter sides that are you know more
kind of authentic so to speak
um and travel and it was just it was
really peaceful for me it was really
really nice
I love that okay so let's talk about the
end of last season your relationship
with Lisa definitely ended on a negative
note of course with her explosive hot
mic rant where do you two stand now
well so first of all it wasn't a hot mic
we saw her remove it and throw it out
and second of all
um I would prefer to call it a childish
tantrum because I don't think it was
really a ram diet uh where do we stand
now that's what you'll see you know
you'll see unfold this season uh as I
would say with any relationship and any
Dynamic that you know shifted at least
for me I can't speak for anyone else the
shifts all come about
um because of a level of understanding
you know if somebody does something that
is hurtful to you or you don't like
um if and you're able to understand why
that happened you know it may be there's
a deeper issue going on maybe there's a
problem maybe it's just a moment of of
jealousy maybe it's a million and one
things I don't know but if you're able
to actually identify what caused that
situation it's much much easier to move
forward so you know forgiveness for me
is very easy that's for me really at the
end of the day the question mark is
always how can I move forward I need to
have some level of trust in any kind of
relationship that you're not you know
out to hurt me
I understand that uh you know your
catchphrases I'm disengaging how much
will we see you disengage from certain
situations this season or are you all in
I mean I don't think I disengaged very
much unfortunately I probably should
have
I love that
um it was really really nice uh to see
you and your family supporting the lgbtq
plus community at the Glad photo shoot
what was that experience for you uh and
for your family and for you as a mom
you know what that was actually one of
my most incredible moments
um
last winter and it was just it was
spectacular because for me you know a
big part of of this process is having a
voice having a platform to to put out
information and
um educate on the things that you care
about and so you know I being involved
with lab was just incredible it's such
an amazing organization and they're you
know doing so many positive things for
the lgbtq community and also having my
family there and participating was a
really big deal to me it was just to me
it was absolutely phenomenal what was
the fan reaction like to that episode
everybody loved it everybody loved it we
sold a ton of t-shirts we raised a lot
of money for glad all profits going to
glad you know that's what it was about
um we still have I think some left not a
lot on our website if anyone's
interested
um so it was just I mean it was so so
good
I love that
um you know you have a a gorgeous uh
company Meredith Mark's jewelry you have
some of the a-listers in Hollywood
wearing your pieces Rihanna Courtney Cox
um who would be ideal for you to wear
one of your pieces who would be like the
dream which celebrity
I mean
okay well here we go because in all
honesty to me they're all clients and I
appreciate them all just as much as one
another but because it would be
impossible and I am like just so
fascinated I would have to say Audrey
Hepburn there we go
uh this is a selfish question on my end
because I am from Toronto would you ever
open up a store here in Toronto
I would be totally open to it I
absolutely love Toronto I mean I love
Canada in general like we've been all
over and it's utterly spectacular
um I would I'd have to figure out the
right circumstances because you know it
is complicated like when I was living in
Canada my business was based in the US
there are definitely certain
complications when you're over the
border so I'd have to figure out the
logistics and some of those obstacles
but yes I I would love it love it I love
it so you're saying there's a chance
there we go yeah there we go
um you know when you uh when you're on a
series now for a couple of years you
know we're all excited to see this third
season are you still having fun
yes I mean the point like if you're not
having fun why are you doing it you know
there's no point if you're not having
fun so yes there are obviously moments
that are not fun I mean that's part of
life though and everything you do if it
was all fun it probably wouldn't be as
rewarding so I guess we have to take the
Bad and the good
um just as we're wrapping up is there
anything any experiences any
conversations uh any moments either from
yourself or or somebody else another
housewife that you are nervous is gonna
get out there that you think fans are
going to really react too strongly
I mean there are so many to be honest
like I just don't know how everyone is
going to react there's a lot of chaos
and there's a lot of you know elements
and again you're only seeing you know
Snippets of our lives and so
there's always backstory and everyone
always wants to explain away but at the
end of the day there's only so much time
and it is what it is so I don't know I
have no idea there's a lot out there and
it will be very I I really don't know
how fans will react to most of the
season to be honest so do you think this
is the most intense season so far
well without having seen like it's hard
to answer but it's definitely at least
matches the other two if not exceeds
which is just so what matches at a
minimum
so entertaining so nice getting to talk
to you congratulations on the new season
I really appreciate your time with us
thank you so much have a great day